twitch's new gambling rules have been in
effect for over a week now and the
result is terrible sure some of the
biggest streamers on the platform aren't
playing crypto slots now but the slots
category on Twitch is now filled with
viewbotters outright scams and streams
whose only job is to get you to go to
another streaming site to watch the same
old gambling and if a viewer does follow
their streamer to one of these other
sites there's a chance they could see
some pretty messed up stuff twitch is an
action now looks all the worse as new
Challengers are trying to cut in on
their action So today we're looking at
twitch post gambling band and asking
how did it somehow get worse
[Music]
alright guys so before I get into the
video I wanted to reiterate that if you
or someone that you know is struggling
with problem gambling there are
resources available to you near where
you live you can follow the link in the
description to visit the National
Council on problem gambling and find out
more alright guys before we get into the
meat of the story I'm going to quickly
summarize our previous video on Twitch
gambling so if you haven't seen Matt you
can feel free to check it out if you
want the full story but I'll make it
quick essentially twitch announced their
intention to ban unregulated crypto
casinos in late September with the full
rules arriving on October 18th and when
we saw them it was basically what they
had already announced it took two years
and incredible pressure from some of the
platform's biggest and most
well-respected creators but it did
finally happen to be clear gambling as a
whole was not banned it was just these
specific varieties of gambling on
unregulated crypto casinos I still think
it's a win because it forced this
discussion to actually happen but it's
not a perfect solution not even close
but now we've had the full rules and
twitch's implementation of them for
about a week and the situation is not
good before we get into the details
though I just want to put things in
perspective for you train wrecks TV who
is one of the biggest gambling streamers
on Twitch pre-ban told viewers that he
made 360
million dollars gambling on Twitch I'm
not just saying this because that number
is insane although it definitely is but
to put in perspective that the casino's
sponsoring train believed them to be
worth more than that amount in terms of
what it would bring in remember they ran
the numbers and these casinos decided
that it was worth it to spend 360
million dollars total on one streamer
Amazon spent 460 million dollars on
rings of power so you know you cut out
some of the CGI trolls maybe train plays
elrond pro bono and try brain can
probably bankroll season three that's
the kind of money that we're talking
about here now that we're in the right
headspace in terms of the money and
power being thrown around in this
situation let's look at twitch's rules
and their actual implementation on the
site obviously if you look at the slots
category on Twitch right now you will
not see train or xqc playing Hand of
Midas but what's there now is arguably
worse now I haven't been staring at the
directory all week I've just been
popping in periodically especially on
Monday when we had our meeting for this
show
and the situation is completely [__]
up on Monday I saw four channels all
streaming the same online casino with
the same weird names and all hovering
around 500 viewers at the top of the
slots category very little chatting lots
of weird names yeah this is clearly
viewbotting it doesn't take a genius to
see that but I guess it's cheaper than
paying to train twice the budget of
Doctor Strange 2 or something I also saw
straight up scams like this rebroadcast
of a drake steak stream with a fishing
Link in it hilariously this 5000 viewers
stream again probably view Bots to some
extent wouldn't be allowed under the new
rules even if it actually was Drake but
it stayed up on the site for almost all
of Tuesday all without a single message
being typed in the chat because you had
to be a follower for three months in
order to chat I wonder why they do that
it's also extreme hard to tell if a
streamer should actually be streaming
the casino site that they're on some are
trying to put the fact that the casino
is regulated in their stream title but
it's very wild west others are playing
exactly the same slot games that you
know the big streamers were playing
before the band but they're making it
unclear on their screen exactly which
site they're using to play those games
this should be disqualifying right like
if you can't show that you're on a
permitted site then you shouldn't be
permitted to stream it kind of makes
perfect sense right unfortunately I
haven't seen much action from twitch on
this and I'm pretty sure if you go to
the slots directory the moment you watch
this video you're gonna see a lot of
sort of gray areas and obfuscation and
some streamers have actually argued the
opposite if viewers can't tell which
site is being gambled on from the stream
alone then it should be okay like this
is total chaos finally some of the
streams in the slot category are just
placeholder streams whose only purpose
is to direct the viewer to a different
streaming site where the streamer is
gambling on those unregulated sites that
aren't allowed on Twitch anymore and
this is where [__] gets pretty bad now
YouTube notably has a policy against
this you can't make things whose only
goal is to get the viewer to go
somewhere else you know like a video
that says hey what's up guys I'm live on
Twitch right now and maybe you delete it
afterwards or something that's not okay
on YouTube twitch's rules for something
like that aren't as clear I look through
the TOs and couldn't find anything
explicit though I will say I'm sure
there are plenty of rules that could be
bent twisted or interpreted in such a
way as to ban those people if they
really wanted to but again as far as I
can tell that's not happening I did
reach out to Twitch about all of the
above but didn't hear back in time for
the publication of this video but these
placeholder streams send sending viewers
to other streaming sites often feature a
site that you might not be familiar with
and that site is called D live if you
know what D live is it's probably
because you have some previous interest
in online political discussion or
perhaps you saw this tweet that's right
d live is actively recruiting any
streamers who might want to continue
gambling on those same sites that have
been banned by twitch and I would have
missed this tweet if not for Andrew Amos
of deserto and his excellent piece about
it so Kudos but D live isn't a place
that we should want twitch viewers to
flock to especially kids the site is
basically the number one place to go to
if you've been banned from all the other
major platforms do their more permissive
moderation strategies which seem to just
boil down to don't do illegal [__] dlive
says that they designate certain
sensitive streams as X content whatever
that means but while I made a new
account and while I was researching the
story that was turned on by default I
didn't opt into it it was already on D
Live's number one earner for a while was
self-identified white nationalist Nick
Fuentes and the site played host to
multiple streams from the January 6th
attack on the U.S Capitol so if you go
there right now I guarantee you you're
going to see and hear some pretty wild
[__] I knew about this site because it
was the site that Alex Jones famously
fled to and that incredibly was actually
banned from which is pretty rare for D
live there aren't a lot of people
getting banned from this site as far as
I can tell that's kind of the selling
point of the whole thing and yeah
Fuentes also was eventually banned from
the site so I popped in for the past few
days at random intervals to just try and
get a feel for what the landscape is on
this dark reflection of twitch I guess
and uh what I saw was pretty [__] up
by far the most popular thing on the
website is sloths nobody is going to D
live to watch enthralling OverWatch 2
Gameplay a fact that this streamer
humorously noted in his stream and
obviously this lost category on D live
has all the potential for abuse and
exploitation that the twitch slots
category had and I suppose in a way
still has it's just that at D live it
seems like nobody really pretends to
care very much about that and that's
kind of the vibe of D live as far as I
can tell just don't do anything that
will provoke an FBI open up kind of
reaction the second most popular kind of
content on D live are news and talk
shows
and who boy and you call the phones and
you aim the antenna at a certain
distance they had they practiced this
and they got it right they they put the
uh the phones around this popcorn and
they they popped the popcorn using their
cell phones
doing to you okay so get your cell phone
away from you
um and then mitigate your house when we
and he warned us when you first put this
stuff in your house you might detox
day three we both got kind of run down
and had diarrhea yeah I just randomly
tuned into someone pedaling a 2008 hoax
about cell phones popping popcorn
kernels and I you're all very
intelligent so I know you know that if
your cell phone could do that it would
do pretty bad things to the water inside
your body too like really bad things so
yeah these categories seem to just be
filled with people regurgitating
conspiracy theories about Q Anon kova 19
electromagnetic radiation and plots by
some unknown actors to install
billionaire Rishi sunak as the prime
minister of the United Kingdom it's like
a snack mix of weird there's something
for everyone you like pretzels you got
pretzels you like the little crunchy
cheesies there's plenty of that too
basically besides gambling d-live is
where you go to get a heaping helping of
Gray grade A [__] like sure I know
there are people just vibing on the
platform I did see a guy streaming
OverWatch too seemed pretty chill but
for the most part it's either gambling
or news and now they're seemingly
growing in popularity by how much
exactly it's hard to say while courting
this audience of former twitch viewers
they're not the only ones and I'll get
to that in a moment but first I just
want to say that twitch absolutely owns
some responsibility for part of this
situation at least daylight gambling
explode on their platform they profited
from it maybe directly but certainly
indirectly in terms of subscriptions and
things like that and they only acted
when they were pushed to do so by some
of their platform's biggest creators not
only that but so far it really doesn't
seem like twitch is very interested in
enforcing those October 18th rules or
even creating some kind of standard that
would allow those rules to be enforced
in a way that makes sense for the
platform it feels a bit like these
October 18th rules were supposed to be
the end of the discussion for some
reason like it's just enough action to
placate the angry viewers and streamers
but not enough actual results to do
anything except stop the biggest
streamers from streaming these things
what other conclusion am I supposed to
arrive at based on what we've seen from
twitch okay back to the other platforms
that are trying to pick up some of these
twitch users there will be people
periodically I'm sure who are banned
from the twitch platform and twitch will
of course refine its approach to content
Banning certain kinds of content in the
future when that happens there will be
fans of those people or types of content
that wanna keep watching they just want
to keep consuming that content so if
there's an option they may follow that
streamer or content to another platform
it's an increasingly well-documented
phenomenon and new Challengers are
lining up one of those is Rumble a site
now known mostly for political content
and mostly from a particular end of the
political Spectrum it's sort of like the
D live situation except they have Peter
teal money and they're trying to sue
YouTube for two billion dollars
good luck on that one but they're also
hosting figures like of course Andrew
Tate who has recently banned from
basically every major platform and did
an interview with Steve will do it of
the full send crew on the rumble
platform this is another great example
of somebody who's been banned from
twitch and many other major platforms
trying to retain that audience on a new
platform but maybe you don't want all
that baggage of an existing platform and
you want to start fresh somewhere else
well Trainwreck announced that he's
building his own and that he wants it to
benefit small and mid-sized creators
he's also teased a feature that he says
will change the game normally I'd be
like yeah sure okay whatever that's
that's what Microsoft said right
Microsoft said that with mixer but in
this case train does have that Mogul
money and I've got to admit I find it
hard to underestimate him one last thing
about train though and this is kind of
relevant to the new platform discussion
he said he's not done gambling on stream
although he obviously won't be doing it
on Twitch instead he hired a developer
to help him build a standalone website
where he can stream those twitch
prohibited activities again if you're at
all familiar with online politics you've
probably seen something like this before
the most common example would probably
be Destiny site destiny.gg if you have a
big enough and vocal enough fan base
they will follow you to your own
personal platform and notably I
mentioned that Nick Fuentes was banned
from D live he eventually did the same
thing building his own platform so it's
clearly an option that can work for some
people it's another potential Minefield
for twitch to navigate and I don't think
the right play is to throw up your hands
and say well we're the biggest streaming
platform in the world we're not worried
I'm sure their competitors even though D
live and Rumble are very unlikely to
take over the video streaming world
would like nothing more than to be
underestimated at this point because
right now twitch is handling a gambling
on their website just isn't cutting it
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock